and according to Hollywood the world's
always any but now we have Hollywood's
best and brightest to save the day or
maybe not save the day but at least
survive it didn't maybe not survive it
but at least exist in it which is
probably funny this is the end so this
is the end is an apocalyptic movie end
of the world kind of [ __ ] happening this
movie stars a few actors but the main
two were Seth Rogen and Jabbar ashell
the best part is they all play
themselves all the actors in this movie
play themselves in this movie I love it
when movies do that and this movie did
it really well everyone goes to a party
at James Franco's house it's all crazy
and then the world starts ending and
then Seth Rogen Jay Baruchel James
Franco Danny McBride Darrel from the
office I know him as Daryl from the a
the guy has a name he's Daryl from the
office and Jonah Hill are all stuck in
James Franco's house and they're trying
to survive the apocalypse that's the
premise of the movie brought to you by
the guys who did pineapple Express are
you excited you should be it's funny
what I love most in this movie are all
the references I'm a big cinephile so
when you have cinephile humor among the
apocalypse it's Christmas early this
year
is it Christmas in summer seriously you
look at James Franco's house there's all
this cinematic [ __ ] there's a Freaks and
Geeks poster in the background he has
the prop arm from 127 hours
everyone in this movie ultimately plays
the characters they always play in
movies but in this movie the typecast
worked it's funny to see them play them
as exaggerated representations of
themselves so when you see one of these
guys acting like a total douche bag
[ __ ] but they know it like the actors
like I'm gonna play a douche bag [ __ ]
version of myself and it'll be fun like
that not every actor can pull that off
but this crew has that I think more
actors should do that that's what I
liked about Emma Watson in this movie
she's in this movie let's be honest
Hermione's hot and in the apocalypse
she's even hotter the fact that she's in
this movie at all is awesome how she
acts in this movies makes it even better
Hermione just stole all her [ __ ] best
part of this movie is coked out Michael
Cera whoever came up with the concept of
coked out Michael Cera is a genius
whoever you are out there thank you you
win an award a medal I don't know what
medal I don't know what award I would
make it the Medal of Honor if I could
but I can't you have my appreciation and
respect first rounds on me the bummer is
he's only in it for a little bit of the
movie but when he is there genius all
the way that wasn't even a thumbs up it
was like the presidential thumb that was
genius all the way and the American
people I want this movie does
lowbrow toilet humor in it I will say
that more notably dipped jokes I think I
say this about every movie made by this
crew it's funny it's great it's clever
its witty and then they're like oh hi
dicks cuz dicks are just simple jokes
and they're thrown in I think Freud
would have a field day with this group
of fellows got a blank spot can't think
of anything
dick you want a dick here's a dick it
might be a dick it might be a real dick
it might be an animatronic take it might
be a CGI dick it might be a product but
there are going to be dicks it doesn't
take away from the fact that the movie
is effective and what its setting out to
do making a laugh about the end of the
world with a bunch of actors who are
laughing it themselves I love it when
actors get together and they even make
fun of the movies they've done that
weren't so good so what's the movie
groundbreaking not exactly I don't think
groundbreaking is the word I think
effective is the word it's clever its
witty its movie humor if you love movies
you're gonna like a lot of the humor in
this movie however it is raunchy
is rank it might be a little over the
top for some people I don't know that
I'd buy the movie on blu-ray but it does
deserve the rating this is the end is
worth buying on blu-ray I guess I could
just say this movies not gonna win over
any new people if you watch movies by
these guys before and you haven't liked
them I don't skip it watch Man of Steel
laugh out loud raunchy comedy and
Superman pretty successful weekend right
so if the world was ending like tomorrow
who would be the crew you'd want to be
stuck with for a week your crew that you
would want to survive it I'm a dead shot
with a shotgun down a hallway let me
tell you whoever it would be comment
below let me know and as always if you
liked what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more
you